l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et pour la première
question la parole est à madame Isabelle
Santiago pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre samedi dernier trois enfants
ont été assassinés par leur père à
Alforville dans ma circonscription je
tiens à leur rendre hommage en ce jour
et à exprimer tout mon soutien à leur
mère à C an nous sommes face à une
réalité tragique depuis le début de
l'année nous recensons 44 infanticides
en France ce constat est accablant il
nous glace dese frroids et brise nos
cœurs n'oublions pas que la violence
faite à ces enfants dans le cadre
familial sont très souvent corrélés aux
violences conjugales quelques jours
après la journée internationale de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
je tiens à rendre hommage aux 121
victimes de féminicide depuis le début
de l'année qui laisse derrière elle 108
enfants combien de temps cela va-t-il
durer la France ne peut absecter cette
situation et doit trouver le moyen de
mieux protéger ses femmes et leurs
enfants plus que jamais nous devons
encourager les victimes à parler mais
plus que jamais nous devons mettre
l'accent sur le repérage des négligences
et des violences pour cela il faut
revoir les protocoles de prise en charge
des victimes vous avez annoncé lors du
ité interministériel pour l'enfance le
développement du nuapè par juridiction à
l'horizon 2027 hors le temps de l'enfant
n'est ni celui de l'adulte ni celui de
la justice cette généralisation doit
donc aller beaucoup plus vite et être
accompagné de véritables moyens ces
unités sont essentielles car composé de
professionnels clés tels que des
pédiatres les médecins légistes les
pédopsychiatres les puircultristes les
psychologues et les travailleurs sociaux
les mineurs sont particulièrement
vulnérables il est temps de coordonner
une véritable médecine médico légal qui
va de paire avec la détenction la
détection des négligences faites aux
enfants
merci je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier verrin ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau démocratique
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Isabelle Santiago d'abord vous dire que
le le drame familial que vous évoquez
nous a tous bouleversé j'ai une pensée
particulière pour la maman de ces trois
enfants qui veut aujourd'hui ce qu'aucun
parent ne devrait évidemment jamais
vivre je tiens à rappeler ici ce que le
gouvernement a mis en place d'abord dans
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants qui sont bien trop nombreuses et
vous l'avez dit dans votre question le
précédent plan pour la période 2020-2022
a notamment permis de renforcer la
prévention des violences sexuelles à
l'enfant à l'école avec un dépistage
systématique à l'occasion des trois
visites médicales obligatoires agir
contre les violences éducatives
ordinaires avec la mise en place du site
1000 premiers jours .fr la mise en place
de cinq nouveaux centres spécialisés
dans la prise en charge du psychotrauma
des enfants victimes de violence ce qui
porte le nombre de ces centres à 15
lancer le déploiement vous l'avez dit de
145 uaped c'est-à-dire des unités
d'accueil pédiatrique enfants en danger
le déploiement de ces uapèes elle
propose de d'accueillir dans un lieu
unique l'enfant victime pour qu'il ait à
la fois des des évidemment un
accompagnement médical social juridique
on avait prévu initialement un nuapè par
département et comme vous l'avez sou
dans votre question il est désormais
question il est désormais programmé une
unité par ressort de tribunal judiciaire
d'ici à 2027 c'est une ambition forte ça
nécessite effectivement le temps de la
mise en place mais si on va plus vite on
va plus vite madame la députée croyez en
notre engagement je profite de ma
réponse aussi pour saluer les travaux
que vous avez réalisé notamment cette
proposition parlementaire que vous avez
déposé que le gouvernement a soutenu
jusqu'à l'inscrire d'ailleurs sur son
ordre du jour cette proposition de loi
doit cheminer maintenant au Sénat et
nous souhaitons que l'examen puisse
aller le plus vite possible et nous
souhaitons même d'ailleurs que les
conditions soient réun uni pour qu'une
CMP puisse aboutir et que les
principales propositions que vous faites
qui rejoignent d'ailleurs en partie les
propositions de la civise puissent être
appliqué pleinement de manière
opérationnelle donc on est dans une
course contre la montre vous l'avez dit
madame la députée mais je crois que
là-dessus l'unité nationale fera loi et
sera source
d'efficacité merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Didier parquan
pour le groupe prenaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'État chargée de
la citoyenneté de la ville et du plan
marseillen grand madame la
ministre si je vous dis à jamais les
premiers vous me répondez évidemment
Marseille vous étiez vendredi dernier
dans la cité fauséenne pour annoncer
l'accélération du plan Marseille en
grand c'est bien la preuve que le
Président de la République et Marseille
ce ne sont pas que des mots ce sont
surtout des actes et du concret pour les
Marseillaises et les Marseillais
Marseille en grand c'est ce plan plan
ambitieux et unique qui a été lancé en
septembre 2021 pour faire de Marseille
ce laboratoire en France des nouvelles
politique publique autour de la sécurité
du logement du social des écoles du
transport et de la culture ce plan c'est
5 milliards d'euros de l'État qui vont
générer 15 milliards d'euros
d'investissement au total c'est aussi 20
ans du budget d'investissement de la
ville de Marseille c'est donc une chance
historique pour notre ville avec des
projets qui vont contribuer à améliorer
la vie de ces habitants madame la
ministre vous avez insisté sur la
nécessité de jouer collectif pour
réussir soit tout le monde gagne soit
tout le monde perd vos mots je les
partage du fond du cœur cette volonté de
travailler à l'unisson doit mobiliser
toutes les énergies pour Marseille et
ses habitants alors madame la ministre
pouvez-vous nous détailler ce plan blanc
quels seront les moyens de cette
nouvelle étape pour faire de le la deuxè
ville de France la capitale de la
Méditerranée je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Sabrina gresti roubach
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté et de la
ville merci monsieur le député madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le député
parquant et si vous le permettez
j'associe tous les députés de Marseille
à votre question pas les députés de la
majorité mais tous les députés de
Marseille donc effectivement le
président de la République lors de son
discours fondateur euh du 2 septembre
2021 était venu annoncer euh non
seulement qu'il se mettait au chevet euh
de Marseille et l'État entreprenait en
réalité un vrai plan de sauvetage de
cette ville qui a accumulé vous le savez
des retards considérables dans tous les
sujets transport sécurité donc si vous
me permettez je reprends juste
rapidement et je réponds précisément à
votre question effectivement je suis
venue euh vendredi dernier annoncer un
plan d'accélération du Marseille en
grand et le Marseille en grand c'est
quoi vous disiez 5 milliards
d'investissement ça concerne 1 milliard
pour les écoles 188 écoles totalement
rénovées reconstruite et dans toute la
ville et j'avais dit c'était un plan de
désenclavement pas seulement des
quartiers Nord mais de toute la ville
l'autre choose c'était 1 milliards pour
les transports dont 500 millions en
investissement c'est 350 millions
d'euros de que le ministre de la Justice
Erric dupomorti est venu annoncer pour
une nouvelle cité judiciaire c'est aussi
et je ça j'y tiens c'est au niveau de
l'anrue 650 millions d'euros sur 10
projets de l'anrue et je suis venue je
finis par le logement rapidement je suis
venue annoncer des opérations d'intérêt
national sur l'enrue c'est une nouveauté
c'est quelque chose qui va prendre forme
dès janvier avec le l'établissement
public d'aménagement euroméditerrané et
où on va créer une filiale pas seulement
pour se faire plaisir mais pour
expliquer en réalité qu'on est capable
de construire plus à Marseille pour les
Marseillais qui qui vivent dans
certaines conditions et vous le savez
notamment dans notre circonscription
dans la votre maintenant de dire on peut
plus accepter que les écoles que les
petits marseillais et dans des écoles
aussi délabré qu'on continue à vivre
dans des quartiers aussi délabré je
m'adresse aussi au député Sébastien de
l'ogu dans les quartiers nord on sait
que ce plan est un plan de sauvetage
inédit initié par le Président de la
République en septembre 2021 je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Henrik Davi pour le groupe la France
insoumise
monsieur le ministre la planète brûle
littéralement avec un réchauffement qui
pourrait atteindre selon les
scientifiques 3 degr en 200 très loin
des objectifs de l'accord de Paris alors
que la COP 28 s'ouvre demain à Dubaï
tout un symbole nous sommes de plus en
plus victimes des conséquences de ce
changement climatique canicule
sécheresse incendie de forêt tempête et
inondation alors en 2017 Emmanuel Macron
inventa le slogan make our planet great
again
alors il y a les paroles et il y a les
actes vous prolongez l'usage du
glyphosate vous renoncez à rénover
massivement les logement vous signez un
nouvel accord de libre échange avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande vous soutenez les
projets de Total vous favorisez la route
avec la
69 dernière hérésie climatique en date
le démantellement de fret
SNCF lundi j'ai visité avec d'autres
parlementaires le centre de fusse surmer
la Commission européenne exige que Fred
SNCF rembourse 5 milliards d'euros car
elle aurait été subventionnée par la
SNCF au détriment de ses concurrents
monsieur le ministre vous négociez un
non paiement de cette dette contre le
démantèlement de Fra SNCF avec à la clé
la session pendant 10 ans de 30 % de
l'activité un report du fret sur le
route sur la route et la suppression de
près de 500 postes alors cette solution
est injuste socialement elle fragilise
l'entreprise et suscite beaucoup de
colère chez les salariés favoriser le
transport routier est une hérésie pour
le climat la santé publique mais aussi
pour la sécurité routière comme le
disait un syndicaliste rencontré lundi
pendant 10 ans on va regarder les
camions rouler et voir crever nos
enfants parce que la SSF ne pourra pas
reprendre un seul marché alors monsieur
le ministre je vous le demande
solennellement désobéissez à la
Commission européenne refusez de
liquider le fr SNCF et engageer un vaste
plan de soutien au frit ferroviaire
quand allez-vous sortir de l'inaction
climatique pour laquelle vous avez été
deux fois condamné passez enfin de la
part au actes monsieur le ministre je
vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député d'avis passer de la
parole aux actes c'est précisément ce
que nous faisons depuis 2017 et la
cation pour une action climatique date
des émissions de 2015 à 2018 vous avez
beau le répéter c'est pour masquer le
fait que vous utiliser l'écologie comme
un prétexte pour votre lutte des classes
dont vous faites du Green wasing en
permanence passz la parole au actes
passer de la parole aux actes c'est
depuis 2018 que l'État met plus d'argent
dans le ferroviaire que dans les routes
cherchez l'erreur quand la gauche était
aux responsabilités dans ce pays on
mettait plus d'argent dans les routes
que dans le ferroviaire regardez les CP
regardez la réalité alors vous
m'interrogez sur le démantèlement du
Fret SNCF et je vous réponds mais comme
vous aviez décidé de faire cette petite
introduction je vous réponds sur le même
ton Clément BAE le ministre en charge de
ce dossier l'a dit et redit il n'y aura
aucun démantellement de fret SNCF le
gouvernement se bat précisément dans le
cadre d'un scénario négocié avec l'Union
européenne parce que si ne se passe rien
c'est 5 milliards d'euros à rembourser
et c'est le dépôt de bilan votre
solution qui consiste à dire c'est
simple il y a qu'à désobéir c'est vrai
pourquoi personne n'y a pensé c'est
génial comme slogan lasoumission c'est
super c'est tellement facile il y a qu'
faut con penser magique le choix que
nous faisons il est pas celui-là il est
celui d'abord de soutenir comme jamais
nos opérateurs ferroviaires 295 millions
en 2022 c'est le record 2023 330
millions 4 milliards d'euros investis
d'ici 2032 uniquement sur le fra de
ferroviaire et enfin le fait que nous
augmentons de 50 % les crédits liés à la
la régénération de nos 29000 km de voie
dans le cadre du Conseil d'orientation
des infrastructures et des 100 milliards
alors dénoncer tenez des propos de
tribune continuez à faire en sorte comme
si rien se passait culpabiliser les gens
mais personne ne vous croit votre petit
manège et la manière d'aller répéter des
propos ne remplace pas l'incurie de ce
que vous proposer il y a ceux qui
agissent et il y a ceux qui parlent s'il
vous plaît changez de catégorie je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Julien
Baillou pour le groupe écologiste merci
madame la Présidente avant de démarrer
cette question permettez-moi d'avoir une
pensée pour une grande militante de
l'écologie qui nous a quitté ce matin
Michelle Rivas a dédié sa vie à
l'écologie de la crirade au Parlement
européen on pense très très fort à à
elle évidemment et à et à sa famille
madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'écologie demain s'ouvre la
COP 28 on pourrait estimer que c'est une
mauvaise plaisanterie une conférence sur
le climat chez un pétrolier présidé par
un pétrolier et pourtant on a
terriblement besoin de ce type de cadre
de négociation pour qu'une COP soit
réussie pour que celle-ci soit réussie
il faut deux grandes ambitions annoncer
enfin la fin des énergies fossiles et je
ne p pas qu'au gaz pas qu'au charbon
mais au gaz et au pétrole et puis un
plan d'action pour l'adaptation et
comment voulez-vous que la France soit
crédible quand sur ces deux sujets elle
est en retard et pas du tout à la
hauteur sur la fin des énergies fossiles
vous avez prolongé les centrales à
charbon vous avez fait un pont d'or à
total pour ouvrir un nouveau terminal
méthanier au Havre pour pouvoir importer
toujours plus de gaz de
schiste la France et l'Europe se ruent
sur le gaz azerbaidjanais en soutenant
l'effort de guerre contre l'Arménie et
le président Macron soutient
personnellement le projet climaticide de
Total icop en ouanda et en Tanzanie et
sur l'adaptation c'est à l'avenant le
ministre de l'écologie vous avez parlé
dans d'une France à 4 degrés je sais pas
si on mesure ce que ça signifie en terme
d'inondation de sécheresse de rendement
agricole en déclin et peut-être demain
des assureurs qui nous lâchent et pour
les mêmes inondations vous aurez donc
ceux qui sont assurés et ceux qui ont
tout perdu la double peine climatique et
sociale où en êtes-vous de ce plan
d'action monsieur ministre pouvez-vous
nous affirmer que la France va porter
ses deux grandes ambitions à partir de
demain à la COP 28 et comment la France
peut-elle être crédible si elle ne met
pas en en cohésion ces grands discours à
l'international et les actes au niveau
national je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des
territoires madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Julien Bayou je veux
saluer d'abord la tonalité de vos propos
sur le fait que nous avons besoin d'un
succès à la COP 28 et et même si des
quantités de raisons le lieu où c'est
organisé la personnalité qu'il préside
peuv nous inciter à être pessimiste si
on ne discute pas avec ces pays-là qu'il
fera et comment serons-nous CAPAES
d'avancer sur le plan global en revanche
sur
l'exemplarité nous savons à quel point
notre pays encore n'est pas dans le bon
rythme mais quand on se compare et qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a aujourd'hui que
un quart des pays qui ont commencé à
baisser leurs émissions nous faisons
parti de cela et pas seulement qui
baissent leurs émissions mais qui
amplifi leur baisse c'était 1 % entre
2012 et 2010
c'est 2 % depuis 2017 et sur la base de
ce premier semestre c'est plus de 4 % de
baisse d'émission c'est-à-dire le rythme
qu'on doit être capable de tenir non
seulement au deè semestre mais pendant
toute la décennie pour être nous au
rendez-vous de nos engagements
climatiques et à la minute où je vous
parle c'est le cas pour cette année 2023
l'adaptation autre grand chantier aucun
ministre de l'écologie avant moi avait
mis si jeose dire les pieds dans le plat
en disant qu'il fallait qu'on se prépare
à ce que la somme des engagements
internation ne permettent pas de tenir
l'engagement des accords de Paris je
l'ai annoncé le 30 janvier et j'ai
annoncé qu'il faudrait un an en janvier
prochain nous présenterons le plan
d'adaptation et vous avez raison sur un
sujet en particulier c'est le volet des
assurances nos caisses pour financer les
catastrophes naturelles sont vides la
multiplicité des sécheresses des
inondations des éboulements on conduit
aujourd'hui à ce qu'on ait un volume de
catastrophe qui ne cesse d'augmenter et
chaque diè de degré compte 1 degr demi
c'est pas un chiffre magique c'est le
consensus scientifique pour éviter des
effondrements trop prononcés mais si on
est à 28 ou à 32 c'est pas la même
histoire sur le nombre de canicules sur
le nombre de jours de sécheresse et sur
le nombre de conséquences on est donc en
train aussi bien d'avancer sur 256
référentiels techniques de repenser le
dispositif des catastrophes naturelles
et des assurances mais plus largement de
repenser notre gestion des vagues de
chaleur et c'est un travail qu'on
soumettra à la concertation au tout
début de l'année prochaine merci
Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
mohamedak pour le groupe démocrate merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'associe à cette question ma
collègue Sabine Tinet en 2018 la loi
esque en instaurant des avancées
majeures telles que le droit à l'erreur
et la simplification des démarches a
ouvert une nouvelle ère dans les
relations avec
l'administration cependant un long
chemin reste à parcourir pour simplifier
la vie de nos entreprises d'autant que
souvent certains allègements sont aussi
annulés
par de nouvelles contraintes d'ailleurs
la récente consultation que vous avez
initié auprès d'elle témoine de votre
compréhension et de l'importance de ces
défis actuels mais aujourd'hui la
jurisprudence une jurisprudence récente
de la Cour de cassation vient encore
percuter la vie des entreprises en
permettant l'accumulation des congés
payés durant les arrêts maladies cela
sème l'inquiétude en particulier chez
les dirigeants de nos PME bien qu'alini
sur la législation européenne elle
soulève de profondes interrogations
quant à sa pertinence surtout dans le
contexte économique actuelle imaginez le
fardeau pour nos PME déjà fragilisé
payer non seulement les remplacements
mais aussi les congés accumulés pendant
les arrêts les conséquences peuvent être
désastreuses sur leur trésorerie surtout
pour les plus fragiles d'entre elles
alors Monsieur le Ministre face à ce
défi quelle est la stratégie du
gouvernement à la fois pour slifier
drastiquement les charges
administratives mais également alléger
le fardeau financier de nos employeurs
tout en préservant les droits des
salariés c'est l'équilibre de notre
économie la survie de nos entreprises et
la sérénité de nos travailleurs qui sont
en jeu nos entreprises comptent sur vous
je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Noël Barot ministre délégué chargé
du
numérique madame la Présidente Mame mes
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Mohamed lquila le Gouvernement
partage votre obsession de la
simplification un sujet sur lequel vous
avez au côté du gouvernement au sein de
la majorité présidentielle agit depuis
bientôt 7 ans avec la loi pacte qui a
permis de simplifier les démarches des
entrepreneurs au début comme à la fin de
leur entreprise en passant par le
franchissement des seuils la loi essoc
vous l'avez cité qui simplifie leur
rapport avec l'administration la loi AAP
et les site industriel clé en main qui
ont permis à la France de devenir pour 4
années consécutives le pays le plus
attractif pour les investissements
étrangers d'Europe la loi dédiée euh aux
indépendants qui simplifi là aussi un
certain nombre d'accès aux droits euh
qui sont les leurs et puis je citerai
également le projet de loi qui est
devenu loi industrie verte qui simplifie
les démarches permettant à nos
entreprises de faire leur transition euh
verte ceci étant dit euh le le travail
doit continuer la tâche est immense et
notre ambition ne s'arrête pas là c'est
la raison pour laquelle Bruno Le Maire
Olivier Grégoire ont souhaité lancer les
rencontres de la simplification et je
veux citer la contribution décisive à ce
chantier de Louis Marguerite Alexis
hizard Philippe bolo un Cécile violent
et Nadj avette des rencontres ont eu
lieu dans une dizaine de départements à
date elles vont se poursuivre dans les
mois qui vienneent elles
conduiront à la mi224 à ce qu'en soit
issu un texte consacr à la
simplification de la vie de nos TPE et
PME qui permettront je l'espère de vous
satisfaire dans vos
demandes la parole est à Monsieur
Benjamin sainthuile pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outreemire et
territoire merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Bruno Le Maire ou à
la personne qui voudra bien se donner la
peine de me répondre le 10 novembre
dernier les partenaires sociaux ont
trouvé un accord sur la nouvelle
convention assurance chaage unédique
accord qui pourtant était financé mais
qui n'a pas été agréé par le
gouvernement considérant que tout n'y
était pas le compte n'y était pas et
donc le Gouvernement a souhaité donner 6
mois supplémentaires aux partenaires
sociaux pour trouver un atterrissage
dans le même temps le ministre Bruno
lomer à grand renfort de communication
nous a dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il
souhaitait voir réduit la durée
d'indemnisation des chômeurs seniors
pour la ramener de 27 à 18 mois cette
annonce nous choc particulièrement parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre mesure que celle
de la punition collective qui nous
serait alors infligée ma question est
donc relativement simple cette position
est-elle la position officielle du
gouvernement en tant que tel ou au
contraire est-ce une provocation pour
essayer d'obliger une négociation sous
contraint des organisations patronnales
et syndicales enfin est-ce un écran de
fumée pour essayer de faire oublier que
derrière le grand discours et la fable
du plein emploi les chiffres du chômage
sont et risque de l'ettre pour les mois
qui viennent je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Carole
Grandjean ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député sinthuile
tout d'abord j'aimerais rappeler le
contexte vous le savez les partenaires
sociaux donc ont négocié un accord sur
l'assurance chômage qu'ils ont signé le
10 novembre dernier cet accord il
confirme au fond les différentes
réformes qui ont été conduites sur
l'assurance chômage depuis 2019 et je le
redis grâce au plein emploi nous faisons
reculer la précarité et nous protégeons
concrètement les Français et c'est bien
là pour nous l'enjeu cela veut dire que
cet accord signé par les partenaires
sociaux s'il pose un certain nombre de
principes il doit aussi demain être
complété par d'autres dispositions pour
favoriser l'emploi des seniors il
renvoie en effet notamment à la
définition des règles à la négociation
sur le nouveau pacte de la vie au
travail qui doit bientôt s'ouvrir je je
le réitère le gouvernement prend à bras
le corp la question de l'emploi des
seineurs ils ne peuvent plus être une
variable d'ajustement de notre marché du
travail nous sommes conscients des
fragilités de notre système d'assurance
chômage et de l'impact sur l'emploi des
seniors qui sont parfois laisser sur le
banc de touche plusieurs années avant de
pouvoir liquider leur retraite c'est un
gâchi considérable de compétences et
d'expérience pour notre économie le
gouvernement sait que ce sont souvent
des périodes qui sont complexes qui sont
douloureuses pour ces actifs et qui ont
encore pourtant tant de choses à
apporter à la société du travail c'est
pourquoi nous sommes convaincus que
notre système doit mieux prendre en
compte le report de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits c'était effectivement un des
objets de la réforme des retraites que
nous avons voté ces négociations
aujourd'hui elles doivent être
poursuivies par les partenaires sociaux
la négociation sur l'emploi des senor
commence tout juste monsieur le député
c'est donc un moment important de notre
agenda social qui doit aboutir à des
solutions concrètes il est normal bien
sûr que chacun prenne sa part il porte
des idées c'est le temps des
négociations et évidemment la fin des
négociations à mi-mars 24 nous permettra
ensuite d'avoir un débat parlementaire
et une tradicction dans la loi comme l'a
annoncé la première ministre je vous
remci je vous remercie monsieur
saintuile madame la ministre a une
question simple vous faites une réponse
longue tortueuse avec des mots choisis
pour noyer le poisson j'espère que vos
conseillers dans la voiture vous diront
que c'était une belle réponse vous
n'apportez pas de réponse dans la
réforme des retraites il y avait rien
sur l'emploi des seniors et les quelques
mesurettes elles ont été balayé par le
Conseil constitutionnel vous demandez
toujours au même des efforts vous avez
réformé l'assurance chômage pour réduire
la durée d'indemnisation des chômeurs
vous avez prolongé de 2 ans la la
cotisation avec la réforme des retraites
vous nous avez parlé de la
conditionnalité du RSA jamais on ne
demande jamais aucun effort aux
entreprises jamais une hypothèse de
sanction de coerition ou même de
bonification il y a rien vous faites
toujours peser sur les mêmes lesfft
quand on est senior on a plus de mal que
n'importe qui d'autre à trouver un
emploi
merci je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Victor
aberber d'assau pour le groupe des
Républicains merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture les agriculteurs de looise
et de d'autres départements de France
continuent de renverser les panneaux de
sortie et d'entrée d'agglomération de
plusieurs communes pour tenter de rendre
visible leur colère à défaut de se
sentir entendu une clé de 17 qure
boulons à dévisser et à revisser et le
tour est joué pas de déchet brûlés ni de
purin ou de fumiers déversés devant les
préfectures ce geste simple sans coup ni
heure dissimule un mal plus profond plus
pernicieux cette action n'a au fond
qu'un seul message les agriculteurs
souhaitent vivre de leur métier cette
signalisation dissonnante se retrouve au
cœur de nos politiques agricoles il faut
consommer français alors que 70 % de nos
fruits et 40 % de nos légumes sont
importés si l'on prend exemple sur
l'élevage bovvin la France représente un
des modèles les plus vertueux en matière
d'élevage mais doit faire face à des
modèles ultra industrialisés avec comme
conséquence 25 % d'éleveurs français de
moins en 10 ans nos agriculteurs
subissent une concurrence déloyale il
faut imposer le respect des normes
appliqué aux produits issus de l'union
européenne par les pays-tiers dont le
cadre d'accords commerciaux je pense aux
négociations avec l'Australie ou le
Mercosur notre souveraineté alimentaire
est en danger l'exemple du maïs en ce
sens est est édifiant la production
française était autosuffisante il y a
quelques années et nous sommes
tristement devenus le plus gros
importateur de maïs de l'union avec des
traitements utilisés interdits en Europe
c'est l'enfer du décor un enfer normatif
et bureaucratique qui rend leur travail
et leur revenus de leur exploitation
précaire malgré toutes les heures la
passion la compétence et le soin extrême
qu'ils y consacrent monsieur le ministre
c'est un avertissement que les
agriculteurs vous envoient afin que
notre souveraineté alimentaire soit
garanti dans les années à venir les
graines de cette révolte silencieuse et
pacifique porteront-elles leurs fruits
dans vos
actions je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier verrand ministre délégué chargé
du renouvre démocratique par merci
Madame merci Madame la la présidente
mesames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Victor aberdasso
merci pour votre question oui monsieur
le député vous avez raison on doit mener
cette bataille pour la souveraineté
alimentaire française et donc pour ça on
doit aimer nos agriculteurs porter notre
agriculture et tout faire pour
accompagner l'agriculture française dans
un environnement mondialisé difficile
normatif face en plus à des dérèglements
climatiques qui ajoutent parfois de la
misère et de la détresse aux difficultés
du quotidien monsieur le député on agit
pour l'agriculture pour les agriculteurs
français je vous rappelle les lois
égalim qui ont permis de protéger les
revenus des agriculteurs depuis 2017
vous nêtes pas obligé de crier monsieur
le député on est dans un truc assez
consensuel en fait là je vous réponds à
la place du ministre de l'Agriculture
donc voilà on peut peut-être s'écouter
je vous rappelle la PAC dans le cadre
européen qui permet désormais d'avoir
des avances de versementsx agriculteurs
avec 4,5 milliards d'euros à date je
vous rappelle la réciprocité des normes
vous avez parlé de du normatif et vous
avez raison c'est un chemin difficile
mais sur lequel la France avance avec
l'idée que les décisions prises au
niveau européen sont la réponse pour
protéger nos producteurs des distorsions
de concurrence en particulier des
produits importés de pays qui le comble
ne respecte pas forcément les normes
qu'on s'applique à nous-même
l'agriculture elle est aussi je le
disais confrontée à des nouveaux défis
le gel la grêle la sécheresse le
président de la République la première
ministre et d'autres membres du
gouvernement étaient d'ailleurs au côté
des agriculteurs touchés par la tempête
en Bretagne dans le P decalais à la
suite des inondations un fond de soutien
exceptionnel de 80 millions d'euros a
été déclenché parce que justement on
veut que les agriculteurs tiennent
parfois contre vent et contre marée ça a
été le cas aussi pour les épisodes
sanitaires je pense en particulier au
fait d'avoir été le premier pays au
monde à pouvoir déployer une vaccination
à large échelle sur la grippe aviaire et
au-delà des crises le gouvernement est
mobilisé pour le défi des transitions
800 millions d'euros mobilisés dans le
budget 2024 pour déployer les démarches
de planification écologique 800 millions
d'euros supplémentaire inscrit au plfg
sur l'accompagnement de ces crises bref
nous faisons face au défi on est tous du
côté de agriculteurs on les aime tous et
vous êtes tous parlementaires concernés
et impliqués merci
Monsieur la parole est à madame Cécile
violent pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
membres du gouvernement chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Solidar madame la ministre des
solidarités et des Familles de France
madame berger lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap fin avr avril le
président de la République s'est engagé
à déployer pour les enfants et les
adultes en situation de handicap 50000
nouvelles solutions d'ici
2030 des solutions qui mèleront création
d'établissements et de servic
aujourd'hui nous sommes quelques députés
à être sollicités par nos dispositifs
locaux qui souhaitent être acteurs de la
mise en œuvre de ces 50000 nouvelles
solutions et notamment les 100 instituts
médicaux éducatif dans les écoles or ces
femmes et ces hommes engagés au
quotidien dans les différentes
structures médicaux social bien souvent
associative sont confrontés à une
absence de documents cadre de cahier des
charges de feuilles de route pour la
mise en œuvre de ces
solutions je connais l'engagement des
bénévoles comme des salariés du
médico-social qui se sentent bien
souvent moins bien considéré que les
acteurs du sanitaire et je veux aussi
saluer leur résilience en effet on
recense aujourd'hui 50000 postes vacants
dans ce secteur d'où la nécessité
absolue de revaloriser l'attractivité de
ses
profils malgré cela nos acteurs locaux
souhaitent se saisir de cette
opportunité et participer à la création
de ces nouvelles
solutions ainsi madame la ministre
permettez-nous de répondre à nos
interlocuteurs où en est-on sur le
déploiement de ce plan je vous remercie
je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame ministre
des Solidarités et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Anne Cécile violent d'abord
vous avez parlé d'attractivité des
métiers et vous avez raison c'est la
raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle quand le
ministre de la Santé a annoncé la
revalorisation vous le savez pour les
nuits et les weekends dans le secteur
sanitaire que nous avons fait la même
chose dans le secteur médico-social et
c'est donc tout le champ du
médico-sociale à la fois évidemment la
question de l'autonomie et des épades
mais aussi la question de celles et ceux
qui travaillent dans les établissements
auprès des personnes en situation de
handicap il n'y aura plus il n'y aura
plus jamais d'oublier du Ségure et je
crois que c'est très important de le
dire il y a pas d'un côté le sanitaire
et de l'autre le médico-social les deux
travaillent évidemment ensemble et je
crois que c'était fondamental pour le
faire ensuite il y a les 50000 nouvelles
solutions et volontairement des
solutions au pluriel parce qu'encore une
fois les personnes en situation de
handicap attendent une pluralité de
solutions qui doit pouvoir se déployer
et la question des IME elle est
fondamentale je crois que pendant très
longtemps dans nos pays dans notre pays
on avait pas envie de voir la question
du handicap et donc quand vous regardez
géographiquement où ont été implantés
les IME ils ont été implantés loin de
nos centre-ville loin de nos
centrebourgs plutôt à l'uré des bois
parce qu'on avait pas envie de
réellement mettre en place de
l'inclusion l'idée de se dire que demain
100 établissements médicaux éducatifs
seront au cœur de nos établissements
scolaires que le médicosocial sera au
cœur de nos établissements scolaires et
qu'ils seront construits avant la fin
2027 pas 2030 mais 2027 pour les 100
nouveaux établissements médicaux
éducatifs dans les écoles c'est une
petite révolution que nous allons faire
c'est la question évidemment de l'école
inclusive mais c'est aussi la capacité à
avoir des solutions pour les enfants qui
ne pourraient pas être dans l'école
ordinaire dans une classe ordinaire mais
qui doivent pouvoir malgré tout passer
la même porte d'entrée que tous les
autres enfants celle de l'école et avoir
accès évidemment à la scolarité à la
scolarisation c'est ça que nous allons
faire le cahier des charges il sera fini
dès début de l'année c'est Laé mission
Carasco ou soulier donc le cahier des
charges sera transmis à l'ensemble des
professionnels que vous évoquez je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Timothé housousin pour le groupe
rassemblement national merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie des
Finances mais aussi de la souveraineté
industrielle et concerne l'avenir des
salariés et du site de la vere holophane
des andelis dont la liquidation
judiciaire vient d'être actée j'ai
d'abord une pensée pour les 208 salariés
de cette vererie centenaire qui viennent
de perdre leur emploi et pour leurs
familles l'an dernier la hausse de 250 %
de sa facture énergétique liée au
mauvais choix de ce gouvernement en
matière d'énergie est venu achever cette
entreprise déjà mise en difficulté par
les changements technologiques
intervenus dans son secteur entraînant
son placement en redressement judiciaire
il y a 6 mois je vous alertais déjà sur
les risques de fermeture et Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué au PME assurit
alors que nous dressions un tableau plus
noir que la réalité et que le
gouvernement accompagné holofhan en vue
d'une reprise viable cela n'a pas suffi
malgré la mobilisation des entrepreneurs
et élus locaux cette fermeture est une
nouvelle perte de savoir-faire et de
compétitivité pour la France alors que
le pays a enregistré en 2022 le pire
déficit commercial de son histoire mais
c'est surtout un cataclysme à l'échelle
locale si holophan ferme il n'y a plus
de raison de rester aux zelis ce sont
les mot d'un salarié dans la presse les
emplois indirects et les retombées
économiques de cette industrie pour les
entreprises et commerces du territoire
sont indispensables tout doit être
misise en œuvre pour offrir une nouvelle
activité de production aux 40000 m² du
site et au tissu local en février Bruno
LEM déclaréit qu'aucun salarié
d'olophane ne serait laissé sans
solution d'emploi aujourd'hui quelle
mesures concrètes prévoyez-vous pour
accompagner le reclassement de ces 208
salariés quel projet de
réindustrialisation enfin à l'heure où
les politiques européennes sont en
partie responsables de ce désastre et où
la France est contributeur net à hauteur
de plusieurs milliards d'euros par an au
budget de l'Union européenne
prévoyez-vous au nom de la France de
demander la mobilisation du Fond
européen d'ajustement à la
mondialisation en faveur des
travailleurs qui peut-être mobilisé dès
lors que plus de 200 person perd leur
emploi en raison de mutation
économique je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Noël Barot ministre
délégué chargé du
numérique madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Timothé housoussin je tiens
d'abord à excuser l'absence aujourd'hui
de Roland lescur ministre chargé de
l'Industrie vous avez raison la la
décision du tribunal de commerce de
prononcer la liquidation judiciaire
d'olophan est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
le territoire et pour les 200
collaborateurs de cette entreprise de
verreeriz installé depuis bien longtemps
dans votre département le ministre de
l'économie et des finances Bruno le ma
s'est beaucoup mobilisé sur ce sujet il
a d'ailleurs échangé sur la situation
depuis que le Tribunal de Commerce a
rendu sa décision avec Frédéric Ducher
le maire des andellliis et dont il salue
et dont il me charge de saluer auprès de
vous l'engagement total sur ce dossier
le ministère de l'Économie et des
Finances s'est engagé depuis le début
des difficultés rencontrées par
l'entreprise avec un un prêt octroyé en
2022 en attendant une éventuelle reprise
de l'entreprise qui n'aura pas suffi
tant cette technologie centenaire ne
suffit plus tout à fait pour adresser
les marchés que traditionnellement cette
entreprise avait pris l'habitude de
servir ceci étant dit ce que Olivia
Grégoire avait dit à l'époque est
toujours vrai le ministère de l'économie
et des finances Olivier Grégoire et
Bruno Le Maire seront au côté de tous
les collaborateurs de l'entreprise
holofane ainsi que du territoire pour
que le site soit repris et qu'une
solution soit trouvée pour
chacun sur les remarques plus générales
que vous avez faites monsieur le député
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire que la
France et le gouvernement ne s'inquiète
pas de l'avenir industriel de notre pays
après tout ce que nous vous avons fait
pour mettre fin à deux décennies
d'hémorragie des usines et de l'emploi
industriel dans notre pays c'est sous ce
gouvernement et grâce à l'action de
cette majorité présidentielle qu'on
réouvre des usines en France et que des
emplants industriels se recréent dans un
pays qui n'en comptez plus et c'est à
cette majorité et au président de la
République nous que nous le devons je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Housin oui 208 familles et tout
un territoire attendait des réponses
concrètes ils n'en auront aucune en
matière d'industrie les besoins des
andelies ce sont des nouveaux projets
les besoins de la France c'est une
nouvelle
politique
merci la parole est à madame mari an
Reed arbello pour le groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et
républicaine madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre ou la personne qui
me répondra mes chers collègues
yaorana alors qu'on dénonce la
paupérisation des retraité ultramarin de
la fonction publique en Polynésie
française en Nouvelle-Calédonie et à
walisfutuna la réponse du gouvernement
est de s'attaquer au pouvoir d'achat des
actifs en leur proposant un dispositif
par capitalisation sur 100 % de la part
majorée de leur traitement
indiciaire tout fonctionnaire actif a
des retenues sur le traitement afférant
à l'indice hiérarchique détenu dans son
emploi pour obtenir une pension civile
en rapport avec ce traitement indiciaire
suite à un article de la loi de finances
rectificativ de
1974 les retenues pension civiles et
sécurité sociale sont faites aussi sur
la part majoré du traitement indiciaire
des fonctionnaires ultramarins du
Pacifique or leur pension civile n'est
calcul est que sur le traitement
indiciaire de base sans sa part majorée
car il existait
l'ITR l'indemnité temporaire de retraite
qui venait compenser ce manque en 2008
le gouvernement en place suite à l'effet
d'auben saisi par certains
fonctionnaires pour profiter d'une
retraite indexée au
soleil alors qu'il n'avait jamais ou
très peu exercé en outreemre a décidé de
programmer l'extinction de l'ITR sur 20
ans promettant de travailler sur un
dispositif de substitution nous y sommes
l'amendement 1404 du PLF 2024 impose un
dilemme un choix de capitalisation
exclusif don l'assiette à 100 % est non
modulable et dont la suspension même
temporaire est impossible pour passer un
moment difficile par exemple le
fonctionnaire du Pacifique a quelques
mois pour se décider pour toute sa
carrière monsieur le ministre les 11500
fonctionnaires du Pacifique ont des
retenues pensions civiles sur la
totalité de leur traitement indiciaire
de base et sa part majorée pourquoi la
pension civile des 280 nouveaux
retraités annuels du Pacifique ne se
base-t-elle pas sur la totalité de leur
traitement indiciaire je vous remercie
merci la parole est à madame Carole
grand Jean ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Rada Berlot
vous interrogez le gouvernement sur les
les conséquences de l'extinction
progressive de l'Un unité temporaire de
retraite je profite de votre question
pour saluer au nom du gouvernement
l'engagement des agents publics en
Polynésie et dans l'ensemble de nos
territoires ultramarins l'ITR est un
dispositif dérogatoire vous l'avez
rappelé madame la députée pour les
fonctionnaires de l'État qui
décideraient de prendre leur retraite
dans certains territoires ultramarins ce
dispositif comportait de nombreuses
limites et c'est pourquoi depuis 15 ans
les gouvernement successifs ont décidé
son extinction progressive et nous ne
reviendrons donc pas là-dessus tout
toutefois nous sommes bien conscients
des conséquences de la fin de l'ITR pour
le pouvoir d'achat des agents et c'est
pour ça que le Président de la
République a souhaité qu'un nouveau
dispositif soit mis en place en
concertation avec les élus et les
partenaires sociaux nous sommes partis
d'un constat simple si les écart entre
le coût de la vie dans l'Hexagone et le
Pacifique sont bien pris en compte
pendant la vie active de l'agent grâce à
une indexation de la rémunération ces
écarts ne sont pas bien pris en compte
lors des départs en retraite c'est
pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre Guerini
que j'excuse aujourd'hui qui est à
l'étranger a proposé un dispositif qui
permet à un agent de la fonction
publique d'État ou à un militaire de
surcotiser sur l'ensemble des compéement
de rémunération perçu sur ces
territoires au régime de la retraite
additionnelle de la fonction publique et
pour s'assurer que l'adhésion à ce
dispositif est un effet immédiat un
montant plancher est prévu aucun agent
ne pourra ainsi toucher moins de 4000 €
annuels vous le voyez alors que aucune
solution n'avait été définie depuis plus
de 15 ans nous agissons concrètement
pour déployer des adapté au retraités
ultramarin tout en maintenant les
principes d'équité et de contributivité
qui fondent notre système des retraites
je vous remercie merci Madame la
Ministre la séance des questions au
Gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue